>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Good evening everybody.
It's very nice to see you
here on this Founders Day,
for this Founders Day concert.
I have two special guests who
we'll be speaking with tonight,
hearing a bit more about the music.
First to my right is Michel
Galante who is the artistic director
and conductor of the
Argento Chamber Ensemble
that we're going to
be hearing tonight.
And we also have Ann Cleare with
us who is the composer of a piece
that has been performed
once I believe on Monday.
And this will be its
second performance.
So you know what they say,
the second time is the,
that's when the magic
really happens so.
>> It was just a warm up.
>> That's right.
And we'll also be hearing some of
Michel's music tonight as well.
So we have two composers
and a really unique
and interesting artist here and
so we're very happen to have you.
Yeah, I thought I'd just kind of
jump into asking about the program
and maybe, maybe Michel I'll
start with you with some of the,
looking at the first half.
What, what prompted you to,
to start working with Ann?
>> Well actually, our clarinetist,
Carol McGonnell is a contrabass
clarinetist as well as,
she plays all of the different
clarinets, E flat, AB flat,
bass clarinet and contrabass
clarinet.
Contrabass clarinet is the
instrument that Ann wrote for it
in a quasi concerto
fashion and she actually can
of course speak best for that.
But maybe I think you
should speak about this,
because they have a
very close connection.
Throughout history there's always
been very rich relationships
between soloists and composers and
here we have one right here so.
>> Yeah, well I've been
working on two pieces
for Carol since about 2008, 2009.
So tonight you'll hear the second
piece in a series of five pieces,
so the series is entitled eyam.
And tonight's has a kind of subtitle
called Taking Apart Your Universe.
So Carol has played
the first piece eyam 1.
It's a B flat clarinet solo.
She premiered that
a few years ago now.
And then this piece tonight
kind of opens up that world
of that first B flat clarinet
solo into the contrabass clarinet.
And she has an ensemble of about
10 instruments surrounding her.
So you'll see the contrabass
clarinet.
It's a very unusual instrument.
It plays as low as
the piano can play.
So it's really earthy.
So we really worked on the,
I think when I met Carol she had
just bought the contrabass clarinet
when she played all the
other clarinets for years.
So I think we kind of really kind of
discovered the instrument together.
Alas, like really it
has four octaves
from the very lowest you can imagine
to about say middle C. And then
after that you get higher register
but through harmonics
and multiphonics.
So we kind of zoned into the
different colors of these registers
and then the ensemble
that's around her kind
of orchestrate these further.
So we've worked on the color of the
instrument for a long time together
to try and give it this
kind of extended life
that the ensemble gives
to it as well.
>> It strikes me that I'm, I
just got to hear a little bit
of the rehearsal, so it's my
first experience of the piece.
But it's, it strikes me that
you really kind of orchestrate
out from the instrument into
the rest of the ensemble
and we can really hear kind of a,
almost like a [inaudible] expansion
into that space that's really
lovely and really nice.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> Yeah, well I guess I'm
hugely interested in tanbur
and it's something very much I think
of the last century for composers
to be interested in very kind
of unique sound qualities
of certain instruments.
And because this is, I guess quite a
new instrument and new for composers
to be writing for it, when you
kind of zone in on different colors
of the instrument, they also, they
introduce a different sense of time
or you know, the way the
sound kind of buzzes.
The low register is
so electronic almost.
So that encourages you to, to
kind of think that way in terms
of orchestration as well.
So it's low register.
I kind of batch with this trio of
bassoon, piano and double bass,
so they're very low with the
low register of the clarinet.
And then the guitar is
matched with another,
the next kind of part
of the register.
And then there's a trio
of flute, cello and violin
that are kind of the next octave.
And then the trumpet and the water
percussion are the highest octave.
And the saxophone then,
kind of veers into this kind
of multiphonic, kind
of harmonic area.
So really, I guess
with the ensemble I try
to almost reconstruct the color of
the entire register of the clarinet
and just make it into
this huge clarinet.
>> And so you also use the
B flat clarinet as well?
>> Yeah, a little bit of the B flat
and that kind of is trying to kind
of bring us back to the solo
that opens the series of pieces.
So then this piece then
kind of expands on the solo.
>> Can you say a bit more about the
rest of the pieces in the series?
Are those already finished,
are they?
>> You hear at the end of the this
piece tonight, the clarinet kind
of slowly hands its
powers over to the flute.
[ Laughter ]
So from there the flute pieces,
the third piece is a
solo bass flute piece.
Then the fourth one
is a contrabass flute,
an ensemble, an electronics piece.
And the last piece of the series
will be premiered in February
with Carol on contrabass clarinet.
The contrabass flutist that I've
been working with Richard Craig
and the RTE National
Symphony Orchestra in Dublin,
so it ends with the two
contras kind of meeting.
>> Oh wow.
>> Actually, I just want to mention.
Professional musicians were
always working and very busy.
And Ann, we had a really
wonderful rehearsal period with Ann
for the last 10 days
working on your music.
But there's something
deeper actually.
Carol has been our clarinetist
from the very beginning
and she is also Irish.
And our Argento has gone
to Ireland many times
and we have a relationship
with this country.
And there's a very strong
of course literary tradition
with [inaudible] and
Joyce and Yates.
Many, many people who,
it's just in their blood.
And I would love for you to tell
the story behind this, but I also,
I haven't had a chance to share with
you that even, I'm always waiting.
I've always been waiting for, to
see this Irish spirit come out,
you know, even suggestions
or even ideas.
I've basically just been you
know, very quietly watching
for these last two weeks.
She doesn't know this but,
but I think it would be great,
storytelling is also a very
big part of Irish culture.
I think it will be
great to hear the story
of you know, a little
bit more about.
>> Yeah, well eyam is
actually a little village
in England, not in Ireland.
But it's one I read about around
the time I started writing the first
piece for Carol.
And it's just this tiny village
that the plague was discovered
there in the 16th Century.
And this tiny village decided
to kind of blockade itself
in from the rest of the world rather
than letting the plague spread
to the outside the village.
So I just took it as a
metaphor really in terms
of what I was talking about earlier.
These different kind of colors,
parts of the contrabass clarinet
that I really wanted to zone
in on and kind of isolate them
and then eventually
let them kind of spread
and become one kind of bigger place.
So it was really just
a metaphor that I used
to get my mind moving I guess.
But what's, I never actually visited
the village but I've been working
on these pieces since
I said, like 2008.
And I always said, when I finish,
the whole five pieces
then I'll go and visit.
Because I only live in Ireland which
is like a short plane away from,
like an hour flight
to where this is.
But I just recently got a
teaching job at a university
in the University of York.
And it happens to be
right beside Eyam.
>> Wow.
>> So I could even live there now.
>> Wow. Five more pieces.
You know, one thing and we can,
I think, speak more about a piece
but one thing that
strikes me as gratuitous
with the programming
tonight is the relationship
between your piece
Ann and the Chirino.
There's almost like both
of them have a very organic
sort of feeling to them.
A very breath centered
type of feeling.
And maybe yours is more
street tone breath.
And the Chirino is the
vibrato breath or [inaudible].
Yeah, yeah.
But there's this real sense of
I don't know, I get the sense
of a breathing entity on stage.
Is that something that
you're looking at
or do you want to speak to that?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I love this
piece the Chirino piece.
Actually for my doctoral studies,
it was one of the pieces I
chose to write a major paper.
So when Michel programmed it
with my piece, I was like wow.
It was, I mean hearing Chirino's
music for the first time,
I was totally blown away.
I think it's, it's so bodily
and terribly I think
psychological as well.
So it's definitely
an inspiration yeah.
>> Maybe we can speak a bit more.
We have maybe you can say a few
words about your pieces that are
on the first have Michel.
>> You know, actually I think
I'll just say one thing.
>> Sure.
>> In terms of concert programming,
I always, there's a convention
of intermissions and
I always have had
for my whole life I've
had this feeling
that when there's an
intermission, whether we like it
or not, people socialize.
People go out and see their friends,
you know, they touch base with them.
And somehow there's a need
to leave the realm of music.
And so I never have you know,
when you accept that there's going
to be an intermission because we
don't have to have intermissions,
that's already a convention
and when we accept
that convention I always feel
like well we need some way
of exiting the world of
music into the social world.
Like and usually, so I always
like to choose an energetic piece.
And I chose to program the solo
piano piece, because it has
that kind of energy and some of
the other pieces like Ann's piece
and Salvatore Chirino's piece, these
are pieces that end poetically,
whistfully you know, quietly and
you know, at the end of pieces
like that, the last thing I
want to do is go socialize.
So I tried to end first halves
of programs with energy.
Something that's going to actually,
something so that the
psychological mood you're
in doesn't contradict you
know, socializing with friends,
you know, saying hi to friends.
You know, so that's the reason
I programed the piano piece.
I'd prefer to leave the clarinet
and piano piece as a surprise.
>> Sure, well maybe
you can say something
about the title of the piano piece.
>> Oh, I think itself, not at all
to be cagey, not at all trust me.
I think it's, it's a
little bit pathological.
I mean totally pathological.
I think it'll speak for
itself, the way, the repetition
and the layers and the obsession.
I think it'll speak for itself.
>> Okay, well we have
on the final part
of the program we have very unique
situation where Ann was talking
about how she was in
some ways orchestrating
out from this deep bass instrument.
We have orchestrating in kind of a
thing from Mahler's Tenth Symphony.
And this is a very challenging thing
to do, I think is a very rewarding
but challenging thing to do and
maybe you can speak a bit about what
that process has been like.
And you've also done other
Mahler projects as well.
>> Yeah, that's actually, Mahler
is a, is an obsession and I,
I feel as a conductor I do a lot of
you know, Beethoven, Bach, Mozart,
Tschaikovsky all canonical works,
I conduct and love and have loved
since I was a child and so forth.
But when I'm, I really have started
to feel the last couple of years
when I, especially when I conduct
normal classical music it's very,
very, clear to me that it's music
from another time and a place.
It's from you know, if it's
Bach, it's Lutheran Germany,
if it's I don't know, Beethoven
it's from Vienna in 18th
and 19th Century and so forth.
And a lot of that music is
emblematic of that time.
Some of it's very religious or some
of it reflects post
enlightenment feelings and you know,
it's a very, very different context.
Even though this is
great music but a lot
of this music doesn't really feel
like it relates to modern life.
It's more, you have to
experience it in a context.
Whereas with Mahler I feel, I feel
when I'm working on his music,
despite the ultra-romantic
surface of the music,
I feel like I'm conducting
music that was written today.
I don't know why, this is a
completely subjective thing,
but I feel like this guy understands
modern problems, modern dilemmas,
modern conflicts, frustrations.
I don't know, he just
gets it, modern crisis.
And for that reason
I've been quite obsessed
with his works for a long time now.
The Tenth Symphony is something
that's particularly problematic
because it's unfinished.
And there's some very strange
things in the manuscript,
basically when Mahler
died he left five folders,
each folder with sketches and
short score from beginning to end
of a movement, one of
his five movements.
And the second movement has,
has scherzo finale written
which is a contradiction
because there's also the fifth
movement is also a finale.
So a scherzo is a contrasting
movement that has a binary form
and is largely transitional
into a finale most
of the time in classical form.
So to say scherzo finale
doesn't really make any sense,
but he wrote this very
clearly and it became clearer
as I was studying some other
scholars work on this piece
that Mahler was really thinking of
this piece as a two part symphony.
One part being the
first two movements
and the second part being
the last three movements.
And that the second movement
really answers the first.
So I did the best I could to retain
the spirit of Mahler as I see it.
And put these two movements together
as one unit for a listening audience
for years, so that's basically
the story of the piece.
>> I mean, there was something
that Mahler did in other pieces too
like in the Fifth Symphony.
>> Three parts.
>> Yeah, yeah and the
fourth and fifth
or maybe just a little bit
more [inaudible] unity.
>> It's in two parts.
The first is in two parts.
A lot of them actually are bi-part.
Actually a lot of the
symphonies are yeah.
Also does the [inaudible],
five song cycle
and one massive movement,
it's in two parts also.
>> I'm wondering if
I can go back to Ann.
There's, if I can kind of project,
you haven't heard the piece yet,
but if I could project
a bit forward into what,
one thing that you're going to hear,
one thing that you
said earlier struck me
and that was the passing off
from the contrabass
clarinet to the bass flute.
Is that kind of this moment where
you have more of a pitch awareness
and then the silence is that
that moment or is it more
of a just a progressive thing
across the entire piece?
>> Yeah, it builds
slowly across the piece.
I mean you'll hear so the
percussionist plays a waterphone
which is this kind of a spikey
small and metallic instrument.
You'll see he's kind of near the
front of the stage at the beginning
and then we walks back to another
station at the back of the stage
that has a [tymp] [assumed
spelling] and another kind
of metallic instrument
that I use as well.
>> You built that instrument right?
>> Yeah, well I, a
sculptor built it for me.
>> Oh fantastic.
>> Yeah, so it's kind of, it's
also a little bit like a waterphone
but without the as much resonance.
So when you hear that sound
its, in a way it's a little bit,
I call it like a kind of
embedded dream in the piece.
It comes back a few times.
And it kind of, it tries to
embed this new flute material
into the music.
And we hear it particularly
then at the end.
So it's that kind of new
percussion material that kind
of brings this flute and clarinet
connection together throughout
the piece.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> It's really and make
sure you take a look
at these instruments are
quite unusual I think a unique
in a very different sound.
Mostly bows are they, is that?
>> Yeah, yeah they're bows.
And they bows are generally prepared
as well so you'll hear all these,
not just a bow but like
a rippling bow, yeah.
>> And I think that the
spikey one is actually on top
of the tympanic membrane right,
so that you get, it acts as kind
of a resonator so that
you can hear it.
>> Yeah, kind of amplifies it.
>> Yeah, it's a very neat
thing so look for that.
Maybe I can ask you both because
I know that Michel I know you have
to get ready to you know,
do a concert and everything.
But maybe I can ask you both about
some upcoming compositional projects
or other, any, whatever type of
projects that you might be up to
that you maybe interested
in, maybe Ann.
>> Yeah well my I guess big
project that I mentioned
of the moment is finishing the
orchestra piece of this cycle.
>> Are there plans to do
the entire cycle together,
performances together?
>> Yeah, it will be amazing but I
don't know how practical it will be.
Like most composers,
I'm not very practical.
So it would involve
like two different,
very different large
ensembles, huge electronic setup
for one piece in an orchestra so.
If anyone would like to do
it I'd be more than happy.
I'm thinking of proposing it to the
people of Eyam actually in England.
>> Actually just to share
one idea with you about that.
There's a, there's a very large you
know, [inaudible], Gerard Grisey.
Grisey was a French composer.
He wrote this massive
cycle, kind of you know,
in some ways I think of your piece.
His piece started with solo
viola, then it goes to a subtet
and it goes to 18 musicians.
This is one piece for solo
viola, one piece for subtet,
one piece for 18 musicians,
one piece for 33 musicians,
one piece for full
orchestra and one piece
for full orchestra and four hours.
And I've, I actually, I went and
traveled to, did my pilgrimage
to hear this piece rehearsed
and performed in Oslo,
2002 with a conductor who's great
at it and knows it very well.
And the biggest problem was that the
first three pieces were really meant
for a small space.
And the last three pieces
were meant for a big space.
And this was a really big
problem because it meant,
I mean really it was
not a good presentation
of the first three pieces.
It worked for the last three
but the first three suffered,
because they needed
and intimate space
and the last three
needed a massive space.
And I think this is, so I think
in your planning maybe
you need some kind of a,
no I think what would be great is
a place that has different size,
different size venues you
know, in the same building.
I think that would work.
[ Laughter ]
>> So again if anybody has any.
>> Yeah.
>> So again if anybody has any
venues they'd like to offer.
>> I'd appreciate it.
And Michel what types of
projects do you have coming up?
>> I have, okay so now
I'm going to panic.
I have a piece that's going to be
premiered in three weeks and all
but one movement are done.
I work with a choreographer named
Miro Magloire and got a commission
from the O'Donnell Foundation and
he's a fantastic, fantastic person
to work with, because he in fact
is a composer and he was a composer
and he studied with
Kagel, so I can speak
with him the same way
I can speak with Ann.
You know, composers actually, we
don't know what we're talking about
and we don't know what each
other are talking about
but there's consensus in that.
So it's like we don't expect
to really understand
each and we're fine.
And with this choreographer, he's
like that I can talk with him,
in any case we understand
each other.
But I was really only just
because I was performing a lot,
I wasn't you know, we
like to have a system
where I give him all the music first
and I gave him all the music
except for a few minutes.
And then he said I'm sorry I
need to start choreographing
and you're going to get a video
and you're going to have to come
up with the rest of the music.
So, so yeah as soon as this is done.
>> Well, this does mark
probably the first time
that a composer has
ever been this close
to the deadline without
having a piece.
>> Oh yeah right!
[ Laughter ]
>> Not exactly unheard of but, well
why if we have a few more minutes,
maybe we can take some
audience questions
if anybody has any questions.
I know you'll probably have
more after you hear the works
but it's a good opportunity
just to ask some questions.
[ Silence ]
There we go.
There's a microphone
will come to you.
>> Oh, I don't need it!
>> We need it for the recording.
We need it for a recording.
>> Thank you very much.
I have a question for Ann.
And it may be a little bit naive
but I hope you'll bear with me.
I wish you could share with us
in a little bit more detail,
what exactly it's like when
you and this soloist are
to use your words working
together on composing?
How exactly do you do that?
>> Well, I mean, I think it's,
for me it starts as basically
as just playing a scale
from the lowest part
of the instrument to the highest.
And I just listen to that
scale over and over again.
And then I start to kind
of explore out from there.
Because as I said,
the different octaves
of the instrument are very different
as you go higher into
the instrument.
And then I, it's just I guess
kind of maybe playing them
in a very traditional way first,
so just with tone and maybe going
into more microtonal, so kind
of in between the semitones.
Then maybe hearing it with
more of a percussive tone
like slapping the reed
rather than just normal play.
And then the clarinet has all
these, especially the contra,
it has all these variations of air.
Like, you can have like you
know, half air, half tone
and then much more air and
that's still very pitched.
So for me in terms of talking about
timbre which really means color,
you know, there's so many different
shades you can get of one note,
say of like you know, middle
C. You can hear that with air,
with a little bit of
pitch, with full pitch,
with a kind of percussive
slap, with a key click.
You know, the pitch is present
in a lot of different ways.
So it's almost I think at first
like building up a little bit
like a dictionary of what
the instrument can do.
And then from there I
kind of have to go away
and think what do I really
want to do with that?
Like where do I want to focus?
Where do I want to put my
focus on and what it can do?
And then you go back and you try,
you pick some things and you go back
and try them, so it's just a
process of trying things together
until you finally find
what is important to you,
what you feel will really
speak for you, yeah.
>> To follow up on that, do you
take into account what feels,
even though you're
taking what you just said
into account what feels idiomatic to
a point or what feels like natural
to the player, do you push against
that or do you explore it that way
in terms of pushing the player
in particular directions or?
>> I don't know, I mean I think
Carol, I mean I've heard her play
so many different kinds of pieces.
Like she's a real, she's such a
great interpreter and she like,
I feel like she throws herself
into the mood of any piece.
Like I've seen her play the
most gentle things to the most
like outrageously like
psychotic things
to like very classical
to very early music.
Yeah, I, like the first time
I saw Carol play was actually
on television in Ireland, I was
about 17 and she was playing,
I was about to start a music degree
and she was playing
Mozart's clarinet concerto.
I thought she just
played it so beautifully.
And I could never thought I dreamed
I'd work with her and I met her
about I guess 8 years after.
And I was like I saw you television
when I was like when I was 17.
So she plays, she plays so much
that I don't feel, I've never felt
like that I've had to, what's
the word like limit anything
in terms of what she can do.
She's very much like you know, you
it's up to you what you really want
to do and I'll bring it to life.
>> That's fantastic.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, we have some more
questions, anymore questions?
There's a couple over here.
[ Silence ]
>> Can you both just give us
a little bit of the background
of how you came to composition?
You were doing music and playing
and how old did you decide
that composition was
what you wanted to next?
>> I'll give a really short answer.
I, I, because I think
it's actually very common.
I was trained as a classical
musician and I had a crisis
and that was the way
out of the crisis.
Yeah, I think and I
really think that maybe
that may be the majority of people.
I think that you know, classical
music is, the music is sublime and
yet there are constraints
about it that make it very hard
to find one's own place in it.
And I'll leave it at that, yeah.
>> I guess and another
I think very common way
of becoming a composer is kind of
falling into it by accident is.
[ Laughter ]
>> Becoming anything.
>> Yeah. Like I didn't, I kind of
ended up in a composition class
when I was 19 by just fluke.
I had, I was in my second
year of undergraduate degree
and I had went to, I was actually
in San Francisco for the summer
and when I came back I got very sick
and I missed the first
few weeks of that year.
And when I came back
to the department,
the head of the department
was like you'll either have
to repeat the whole thing or
you'll have to take certain classes
that haven't handed
in assignments yet.
So that's how I ended
up in composition.
>> That's profound.
[ Laughter ]
>> But it was, it was really
amazing because the name
of the class was Making
and Breaking Instruments.
And the first piece I heard
was Berio Sequenza for voice
and like I really hadn't
grown up around composers.
I really didn't even know that
there was still living composers.
So the, when I heard Berio
Sequenza for voice I was just,
it felt like a new
world that opened.
And I just kept composing
from there really.
But it was something that
suddenly appeared and it kind of,
I mean looking back it makes
sense to me that it you know,
I've always wanted to
do something with music
but it was never going
to be performance.
Maybe I felt teaching
but now when I look back,
before that it makes sense that
I would want to be a composer,
because I've always been
interested in sound I've always kind
of heard music as like
telling me something.
I've never seen like music as just
music or just kind of pure sound,
it's always been something
kind of narrative to me.
So it kind, it makes sense even
though it was something I only
discovered when I was maybe 19 so.
>> When you're working on.
>> Sorry.
>> That's quite all right.
When you're working on
a new piece like this
with a particular instrumentalist
you're working with
and you're exploring the limits of
the instrument and perhaps things
that had not been explored before,
you have a working relationship
with the instrumentalist that
you can talk about you know,
this is what we're going to do here.
And you know this is the
kind of shading that's going
to be done here and so forth.
But then when you think
about passing this
on to future generations, you have
to find some ways of notating all
of this and that has always
been a fascination of mine.
How do you, you know, how much
of your process is finding ways
of notating that in a way that
will convey to future generations
that will not have
you as a resource.
>> Yeah, yeah that's
a very good question.
And it does occupy a lot
of time in this research
or collaborative time I spoke about.
So we'd also when I found
something I thought I'd focus on,
we'd talk about how to notate it.
But a lot of the sounds too,
you know of the entire ensemble,
they're, they're kind
of unstable in a way.
They're these very fragile
timbres that you know,
in a way I put them there so
they kind, kind of fluctuate.
So that fluctuation in a way
is kind of meant to be built
into the notation as well.
I guess all I can really
do is, I mean it's great
when you get a really good
realization like tonight,
it really sounds like a document
for the sound that I'm looking for.
And then you know, I try to explain
it the notation, the graphics
and the introduction
to the score as well.
But as I said, it's now good to
have a sonic document as well
that I can give people and say this
is what it sounds like you know.
>> You know, that's something like
I think Lachenmann is now doing
that for his string writing is
having a DVD that goes with the work
as a demonstration type of thing
so you can have the visual along
with the audio of just
some of the techniques,
so that's something you could
also [inaudible] for too.
>> She actually, you made
videos, she made videos.
>> Oh you did?
There you go.
I think we have time for about
one more question if there is one.
If not then I'd like to
thank our guests so much
for the music we're
going to hear and also
for speaking with me just now.
So.
>> Thank you.
>> Ann Cleare and Michel Galante.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov